Share one with you
Cough soup
that is very popular
among mothers
It's apple onion water
Knock knock knock knock knock
That's it
Knock knock knock
Qīng fèi xiè huǒ (transliteration)
Improve cough and asthma
Improve respiratory tract
It also improves
chest tightness, chest pain
vocal cord inflammation, etc.
It can all be relieved
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
I want to share this episode with you
Lung health status
Check these 5 symptoms
Does drinking apple onion water really work
for a cold?
Sore throat
Press your ears
2 acupoints for pain relief
1 way to check
whether your lungs are healthy
Traditional Chinese Medicine says
Fèi zhǔ yī shēn zhī qì (transliteration)
Qi is transported by the lungs
Promote the coordinated operation of meridians
and internal organs
Once the lung qi is deficient
Poor blood circulation
Decreased resistance
whole body feels like it has lost its power
and becoming more and more tired.
What?
How do you know?
if your lungs are weak?
The editor, I ask you five questions
Look at you
Is there any sign of lung deficiency?
Dear fans
You are the same now
Check yourself
Do you have any symptoms of lung problems?
1. You look pale
The sound is small and weak
Too lazy to talk?
have
When I'm tired
I'm really too lazy to talk
2 You will often feel tired and out of spirits
Do you get out of breath when you move?
Recently, the whole person
So sleepy
3 Are you the type of person
who gets a cold easily
or is very afraid of the cold?
I am afraid of the cold
In winter,
hands and feet are like popsicles
4 You will lose strength when you cough
The sputum you cough up is white
Is it clear and sparse?
I don't have this.
5 The color of your tongue
It is light
Is the tongue coating white?
When I brushed my teeth today
I took a look
The tongue is pink
The tongue coating is white
Is this normal?
Congratulations to you, editor
Your lungs
Still healthy
Everyone
The symptoms I just mentioned
If you have
Just watch out for your lungs.
What if
there are only three problems?
That needs attention too.
Your own health
You have to take care of yourself, right?
Like the weather now
It changes all the time
Others have colds
You catch a cold
Frequent sore throat
People are coughing
You cough too.
Pay attention
This is probably
Your lungs qi are not in good condition
Maybe it's lung qi deficiency.
It will cause poor blood circulation
resistance will also deteriorate.
How to keep lungs healthy
Let me teach you an acupuncture point
on your hand.
called yú jì acupoint (transliteration)
This is the acupuncture point of the lung meridians.
Open your palm
Palm close to thumb
The color of this position
If the color near the thumb
is whiter
Muscle bulge
This place
So called dà yú jì (transliteration)
It's right here
The base of the thumb
midpoint of the line connecting the wrist
This acupuncture point
called yú jì acupoint (transliteration)
Let's knock
this acupuncture point.
You listen to me
Knock gently
with your hand
This yú jì acupoint (transliteration)
Knock knock knock knock knock
That's it
Knock knock knock
Qīng fèi xiè huǒ(transliteration)
Improve cough and asthma
Improve respiratory tract
Improve
chest tightness and chest pain
Vocal cord inflammation, etc.
It can all be relieved
At least every time
You need to knock 30 to 50 times
That's the way
Knock knock knock like this
Knock knock knock
We say
WǔXíngshēng kēi yuán lǐ (transliteration)
Knock like this
Can nourish the lungs and produce body fluids
And what about
Because gold produces water
So it can also produce kidney water
Sufficient lung qi can nourish kidney water
This is what Chinese medicine refers to
Jīns huǐ xiāng shēng(transliteration)
Jīn shēng shuǐ(transliteration)
Can relieve dry mouth
Really?
Feel mouth
is watering.
Is there any food?
Can nourish the lungs
Drink apple and onion water for cold
Does it really work?
Have a cold.
Is drinking apple and onion water effective?
have
Such a big change in weather
Hot and cold
At this time
The throat will itch
I have a stuffy nose and want to cough.
Share one with you
Cough soup
that is very popular
among mothers
It's apple onion water
Just these two things
Apple and onion diced
Throw it into the rice cooker
Cook
It is a cup of cough killer
that moistens the lungs and relieves coughs
Take care of your airways
It is said that apple onion water
It's been around
since my grandma's time.
Apple onion water
Very popular
Ha ha
When you have a cough
It is a warning sign of lung qi imbalance
At this time
Not by suppression
Rather, it depends on adjustment or conditioning
Apple and Onion Water
It's just great
Health-nourishing drink
Applerùn fèi shēn gjīn(transliteration)
Also contains various polyphenols
Anti-oxidation and anti-aging
Improve immunity
Even colds and flu
All viruses
No one dares to get close
onion
Can help you
Get rid of thehán qì (transliteration)in your body
Nose respiratory tract
It's smooth
Lungs open
Coughing will naturally decrease
Isn't it
How long does this drink last?
Only then it will be effective
You drink it for a week and see
Lung Qi is unblocked
The cough is gone
The complexion is also rosy
The spirit is back
There are three types of people who are suitable
1. In an air-conditioned room
People who stay all day
Frequent cough and dry itching
People who keep coughing
2. Coughing when exposed to cold wind
3. White and thin sputum
People who breathe heavily
These three types of people
Lung Qi deficiency is the most important thing to replenish
What are the specific methods?
The editor will share with you
in detail at the end of the video
Proportions and production process
Remember to watch till the end
What to eat to nourish the lungs
3 white ingredients
Clears rè (transliteration) and resolves phlegm
What to eat to nourish the lungs and reduce coughing
In fact,
no high-grade medicinal materials are needed.
You can buy it in the market
Chinese yam, white fungus, white radish
These three are white ingredients
White ingredients
Can nourish yin and promote fluid production
Regulate lung qi
Helps you repair lung tissue
Nourishes the lungs, moisturizes the throat, and reduces phlegm
Take care of your airways
Yam can replenish lung qi
Lowering blood sugar and blood lipids
It's recorded in Míng yī bié lù (transliteration)
The benefits of yam
Relieve low back pain
Léi shòu(transliteration)
You can eat it for a long time
Clear eyes and ears
Light body
Have lower back pain
People with weak constitution
People with poor hearing and eyesight
Eat cold mixed yam
Yam and Pork Ribs Soup
They're all great
Chinese medicine says
Fèi zhǔ pí máo xǐ rùn ér è zào (transliteration)
Tremella is rich in gelatin
Can nourish yin and moisten the lungs
Relieve dry cough
Like natural
Lung moisturizer
People with poor lungs
When you cook white fungus
Cook until the gelatin
is released
Just drink it
Already a little
Thick and sticky
Nourishing the lungs is enough
If you have excessive phlegm
Itchy throat problem
It's the shī qì (transliteration) in the lungs
that's blocking it.
Come
Eat a bowl of white radish soup
Can clear away qīng rè (transliteration) and resolve phlegm
Soothes Qi and relieves cough
throat hurts so much can't speak
Quickly press the two acupoints on the ears
You have a sore throat
that you can hardly speak
The throat is like
Have ever been cut by a razor blade?
have
It's really painful.
physician
You can teach us how
Quickly relieve sore throat
no problem
I will teach you two acupuncture points on your ears
Simple and fast
Relieves throat pain
The first acupoint is treatment
It hurts like swallowing
called Yàn (transliteration) acupoint
Where is it?
Above the external auditory canal
It's about 12 o'clock.
This acupoint is called the Yàn (transliteration) acupoint
You press the Yàn (transliteration) acupoint
That will stop the pain.
The second
Do you have pain in your trachea and throat?
If so
Press theHóu(transliteration) acupoint
It's right next to the Yàn (transliteration) acupoint
Probably
11 to 10 o'clock position
This place
good
In these two acupoint
You press and rub
What is Yàn (transliteration)?
What isHóu(transliteration)?
From an anatomical point of view,
In the throat
The Yàn (transliteration)is the uppermost opening of the esophagus.
The Hóu (transliteration) is the uppermost opening
of the trachea.
So when you can't swallow
It's a problem with the upper esophagus.
When you have trouble breathing
It's a tracheal problem
This just distinguishes.
What is Yàn (transliteration)
What is Hóu (transliteration)
When you have a sore throat
When it hurts so much that swallowing hurts
You press with your fingers
These two acupoints
When you press
It will be a little painful
That's right
That is to say, you press the right place
Press for 1 to 3 minutes
Relieves sore throat quickly
I remember more than 20 years ago
Have had a goiter before
It's inflammation in theYān hóu(transliteration).
press here
Then press the thyroid gland.
It's a thyroid problemcaused
by throat inflammation.
Then you press theYān hóu(transliteration).
You can treat your thyroid problems
Also solved
1 movement supplements lung qi
Can see things clearly at night.
Give you another bonus
If you keep coughing
Eyes will become presbyopic again
I'll teach you a trick
InYǎngshēng dǎo yǐn fǎ (transliteration)
There is an article called yǎn mù mén (transliteration)
What are the benefits of this?
The method is
Stretch left shin
Right knee bent
Nà yā zhī wǔ xī zhǐ (transliteration)
What this means is that
Straighten your left leg
Then bend your right foot.
Then the body presses forward.
Take 1 deep breath
twice
Up to 5 times
This action can replenish lung qi
Eliminate Qi deficiency
caused by qi deficiency
blurred vision
You often do this action
A few months later
even
You can see things at night
just like you can during the day
It's very clear
This movement looks like a cramp.
How to make eyes brighter
Good question
Traditional Chinese Medicine says
Fēng wèi bǎi bìng zhī cháng (transliteration)
Qi deficiency cannot resistfēng xié(transliteration)
Dizziness, headache, and cough all came
This trick is actually
Qi and blood gas station for the eyes
Help you
Open up the meridians
Bī hán qì (transliteration)
Nourishing the lungs
It can also make the eyes see more clearly
After fifty
The most important thing to do is not to take tonic medicine
but to nourish the lungs
Improve your eyesight
Do it for 1 minute every day
Lung qi is sufficient
The complexion turns red
eyes lit up
More energetic body
How to make apple onion water
1.Two apples and an onion
Cut into small pieces and set aside
2.Prepare a large bowl
Turn the empty cup upside down
Place in the center of the bowl
3.Place the chopped apples and onions
evenly in the bowl
around the cup.
4.Add 500cc of water to the outer pot
5.Cover the pot
Start the rice cooker
6.During the cooking process
The cup will automatically suck in.
7.Remove the cup when finished
There is in the cup
Apple and Onion Water